okay so it's very likely that if you've
ever come within a
country mile of a competitive shooter
you've had some
sweaty try-hard try to evangelize you
about the benefits
of stretching your in-game resolution
from 4-3 to 16-10
to fricken 5-4 everybody who's anybody
is doing it simple bolo hell
even those g-fueled fortnite kitties all
prefer to bang out against those
wide thick with two seas player models
why because by most top competitors
lights
it's one of those things that just feels
better what we want to figure out
is whether it's actually better
okay so first things first what is a
stretched resolution
and how does one enable it as i'm sure
most of you are aware
most if not all modern video games are
played in a native resolution
of 1920 by 1080 and a default aspect
ratio
of 16 9. and for the vast majority of
titles
you stick to 1920. the outlier of course
is shooters first person third person
doesn't matter if there is a way to run
that [ __ ] in stretched
somebody will why well we'll get to that
for now let's talk about what it entails
stretching a resolution
requires reverting your game to a
smaller non-native
aspect ratio most commonly 4 3 16
10 and 5 4 in that order and full
screening it
such that the black bars that would
normally appear on the sides
are replaced with the reduced yet
widened field of view
how exactly do you do this well it
depends on the game
in siege for instance it is extremely
straightforward
you go to options click display and
simply lower your aspect ratio
you don't even need to touch the
resolution in counter strike however
which is where
all of this stretched business got its
start and where we'll be focusing the
bulk of our attention
it's a tad more complicated go to video
settings change your aspect ratio to 4
3 or 1610 and choose whichever lowered
resolution you prefer
next right click your desktop open your
nvidia control panel
go to adjust desktop size and position
check the full screen box and click
apply
for those who own amd cards go to amazon
newegg etc type g-force into the search
bar
buy yourself a real graphics card and
keck wait for it to show up in the mail
memes aside i literally have no idea how
you do this with an amd card
i didn't even know people still bought
amd cards whoa whoa
dimitri slow your roll i don't know how
much you actually know about graphics
cards considering you spend most of your
time simping for phlom
and being wildly okay at retakes but
it's not 2010 anymore
amd's come a long way as far as hardware
and software is concerned
as long as you aren't trying to play
minecraft with ray tracing on or
do what i do for a living then the amd
cards can actually offer a better price
to performance ratio than the high-end
nvidia cards
and according to the fine folks over at
ltt you can actually get better
performance
in cs go with an amd card so
checkmate nerd wait hold on is golden
allowed to just insert himself into my
videos like that
dick okay back to talking about
stretched
now keep in mind this will make your
game look like
[ __ ] it's just a question of how [ __ ]
the highest 4-3 resolution is 1440 by
1080
so it comes closest to preserving the hd
look of 69 the issue is that it also
makes it look somewhat
jagged the smoothest cleanest and
so-called
god res is 1280x960 which is what the
vast majority of professional players
use
now you can go even lower of course
which a lot of competitive players do
since it can
increase visibility this comes at the
cost of
increased blurriness though so it's up
to you to decide what scans best
to your eye now if you're interested in
the story of how stretched came to be
and how it was essentially popularized
by counter-strike legend
get right you can check out our offbeat
on rops who for a long time was
pretty much the only truly top tier
professional to run his game in a native
resolution
personally if you ask me why would i
pick 16x9 then
i think it's just logic because why
would you
pick a resolution that's small but you
the other one
is literally giving you more more field
of view i have like a situation every
day my
in my practice maybe that's i see a guy
that my teammate doesn't you know it's
very often these things happen okay so
why
play and stretch why would somebody
willingly sacrifice
pretty much half their field of view
speed everything up
and make their skins look like [ __ ] well
for starters
because it makes the player models
bigger depending on what resolution you
run
you can decide just how wide you want
your boys to be
whereas 16 10 makes them only a tad
beefy
4 3 really gives them some girth 5'4
is straight up wide putin now in theory
this is a good thing
bigger target make easier for boomstick
to click head
right well in a sense yes
but as with all things nerdy and
scientific
it's not that simple is it true that
stretched stretches out the player
models making them easier to see
and theoretically hit yes
the issue is that it stretches out
everything else as well
your crosshair view model the world
around you
remember in physics everything is
relative
even esports the downside to this of
course and the thing that
i personally hate the most about
stretched
is that it gives everything the illusion
of moving
faster given that everything is
traversing more pixels to make the same
movement everything from you your
sensitivity and the enemy player models
scream across your screen giving things
a sort of
arcadey feel which hey a lot of people
really like i use 1280 by 960 stretch as
it makes
everything a lot more vague and easy to
see and also
it makes the game feel faster which in
the end makes it feel more fun for me
the reason for this of course is that
stretched literally accentuates
everything you do from one taps to
stutter steps to spray control
stretched has a tendency to make
everything feel more
granular or molecular the theory is that
since being
discovered in the early 2010s it's
afforded players with a sort of
hyper awareness that permits them to
play better
i felt like that the models itself
became more
fatter in a way or like more dragged out
i feel like you can keep them more
easier
and you can actually feel the sprays
itself it was like
actually hitting more and more and i
think that's
basically why i started using it because
it felt more
smoother in general when i walked around
and like bunny jumping or shooting and
spraying and all that kind of stuff for
years the general consensus has been
that resolution is just a matter of
preference
but with siege superstars fortnite
phenoms and the vast majority of cs go's
most elite competitors
all running widened resolutions you
can't help but wonder
is there not some objective sense in
which stretched is
as we counter strike stans often say
just better in an effort to find out i
sat down with
madison klarkowski a professor of
computer science at the university of
saskatchewan
who specializes in computer human
interaction
she explained that while there's still
tons of actual
hard-nosed scientific research to be
conducted on this
topic it could very well be that the
widespread use of stretched at the
highest levels of play
could be suggestive of the fact that
it's well
better well obviously there is something
there right it can't just
be um the to use like the traditional
meaning of the word meme it can't just
be some social meme that's being adopted
right there has to be
so i i'm sure that there is something um
there that is assistive to
to the pros to anyone who uses
stretcherize and finds it helpful to
them
remember earlier when i qualified the
whole bigger player model thing by
pointing out that it's relative
well according to professor klarkowski
that relativity
may not matter when you're playing you
know you're focused on
the target you're not focused on the
walls around you which are larger the
corridor which is larger right
so by making that model um
i guess relatively larger it might not
matter that the surrounding environment
that the
other items on screen assets on screen
are also larger because
you know the holy grail the item that
you are actually focusing on
is larger itself so that's the target
that you're tracking she also speculated
that the difference in speed may not be
as important as the difference in
size that it might actually be easier
for certain players to acclimatize
themselves to hitting a
faster larger target as opposed to a
slower
skinnier one let's assume like
hypothetically that
you know a flicker does better with
someone like fast movement than a
tracker right because a flicker just has
to go from
a to b to get to that you know resting
point or that standing point
of the of their target right people who
are you know in this hypothetical world
where flickers can
keep up with those faster targets better
you might find that
they prefer the mode for that reason or
that they adapt more quickly to the mode
for that reason of course
the most commonly spouted downside to
stretched
is the fact that you're chopping away
half your field of view
the question is whether you need it now
true enough
it is fairly common for someone to get
four three
meaning that they missed an enemy who
they otherwise would have seen
had they been playing a native but when
you use like a
69 or sushi you see so much more and you
can notice that when you're sitting and
watching like a
batch of professional match when you see
like an enemy just walking past
like oh my god how can you miss that but
then you're like for free
for free because he's pushing out with
no cover and al who's just hiding behind
the rock he'll spot him does he see him
does he see him four by three
four by three there's no way he didn't
see him on the right side no
way they walk right past each other
what kind of circus is this but for the
most part that lost fov
isn't something you're gonna miss
especially since as most competitors
will tell you
playing and stretched allows you to
focus doubly
on what you do see four by three all day
10 24 black bars bro that's how we roll
four by three it makes it easier to want
them four by three
more tunnel vision what's really cool is
that according to professor klarkowski
there's already an accepted term for
this type of
tunnel vision there's this concept
called inattentional blindness
and this concept describes the filtering
out of visual stimuli
that your brain determines to be
non-essential well it can be detrimental
when you miss out on critical
information because you get it's about
the tunnel vision right
but it may be that you know actually um
emphasizing this
and emphasizing tunnel vision and you
know emphasizing
inattentional blindness and the removal
the filter of non-essential visual
stimuli
is what makes playing in stretch resin
4-3
so potent so is stretched better
or is it just a fad that's taken on the
illusion of being there
well obviously without some actual
rigorous study
there's no way to know for sure but
there's no denying the fact that
ostensibly it can't just be preference
there's got to be more to it than that
no i think there has to be something to
it i mean if the majority is doing it
then
i guess it's not it's not just for the
fun of it there is something to it and
it's something that would benefit from
further exploration i mean you can't
just you know discount
the opinion of many many many experts
who are choosing this alternative
um display method in fortnight for
instance
epic straight up banned stretched
resolutions from competitive play
invoking the ire of competitors
everywhere
one of the things that lends credence to
this theory is the fact that when they
were designing
valorant riot actively tried to make it
so that you couldn't play and stretched
since by their reckoning you shouldn't
need to now
whether this was because they thought of
it as actually offering a competitive
advantage
or just because they wanted their game
to look pretty while streamers
broadcasted it to the masses
one thing is for sure it sparked a
conversation about the science
behind stretch i'd be interested to see
what prompted them to say that like is
there data that they have
on is that data you know from expert
players
is it do they actually have telemetry
data do they have performance data
that would be really interesting to know
if like maybe riot does have an idea of
what
um the driving factors behind any
advantage from
from stretcher as any competitive
advantage from stretch res might be
it could also be that different games
have different so-called
god res's remember cs go and valorent
have different fovs
different visibilities hell in siege you
can even adjust your fov
rendering stretched at least marginally
less enticing
there's no shortage of high-level
valorem players talking about how 69
just
hits different and while i'm actually
inclined to agree
we can't really know for sure since
there's no point of comparison
is 16-9 legitimately better or is there
some sort of stockholm syndrome going on
of course as professor karkowski was apt
to point out
we won't know until we start subjecting
the constituents of these various
shooters to different kinds of
experiments
what we do know is that contrary to
popular belief
res might honestly not just be a matter
of preference
the ideal approach would be getting
telemetry data
um and you know seeing people's
performance versus that chosen
resolution native or stretched
do they tend to um rely more on flicking
or are they trackers or are they
entry fraggers or are they operas and it
would be really really interesting to
see if there was some kind of
association
between playstyle and chosen res and
once we have that information i think
that would then allow us to delve a
little deeper and make more
um i guess not really conclusions but
um inferrals about what exactly stretch
reds could be helping
so while playing stretched won't
instantly turn you into a god
who's to say that it won't give you that
slight little added advantage
in your journey to become one
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you